[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
thank you for joining me
on a late start to an early stream uh
that's right the road to 2000
is happening in the late afternoon early
evening tonight
on accounts of some exciting things
going on later in the evening
so last week i went over some games from
the magnus carlson invitational went
over two
very exciting must-win games where
magnus carlson and jan
naponishi both won in must-win scenarios
very exciting stuff
unfortunately for them they're both big
losers in this tournament
so i thought it was only fair if we took
a look at some games
by anish geary who did win the
tournament and i wanted to start
with uh one or two games from the tie
breaks of course anish and yan played in
the finals
made it all the way to the tie breaks
and i wanted to see how those games
actually went down it was exciting stuff
so let's just let's just go let's get
going we've got anish here with the
white pieces he starts with e4
we get c5 knight f3
e6 c3 and a c3 sicilian
we get d5 and e5
by white and now we are basically in
some sort of strange
c3 sicilian french defense hybrid after
d4
we should just be in a normal french by
white now
black does have the option to play d4
here himself and then we get
into some unique lines but that's not
what jan went for jan simply playing
knight c6
now we get d4 and this is essentially
just a french defense
advance variation with white playing you
know white could have arrived at this
by playing e4 e6 d4 d5
e5 c uh c5 c3 knight c6 knight f3 that's
the other move order we could have
gotten here
uh so bishop d7 by
yawn is fairly normal stuff at this
point
we get bishop e2 by anish knight g to e7
knight to a3 this is very very much
mainline theory
uh notably after knight a3 this bishop
is temporarily blocked and so
uh white never has to worry about any
captures and captures on a3
although this is generally not the
greatest idea by black
anyways on account of some of these dark
squares already being a little bit loose
and the stark squared bishop being very
valuable we get c takes d4 by yon
c takes d4 by anishigiri knight g6
and now uh to the point of bishop takes
a3 not really being a threat
the main move here is actually h4 and i
forgot lyches does this little bubble
thing
they're sort of exposing which moves are
sort of questionable
so as the lead chest bubble says
the main move here is actually not f5
which is very sensible right
it adds more pressure to this pawn on d4
sort of the classic french defense line
of attack and then white would play
knight to c2
this is the point of playing knight to
a3 is we can add some extra support to
the pawn here
instead though we'll see that jan has
some different ideas with this move
knight g6 so again the
most common move here is h4 for white
trying to immediately harass this knight
on g6
but instead niche plays the rather
simple knight to c2
so why did yan play knight g6 and not
knight f5
this is the first question i have for
you in the chat room and yes
uh oh wow this is a niche geary with
some
sort of uh you know check mark
uh by his name i don't know if this is
the real niche gear i suspect not but
the check mark
it's very very convincing in the chat
room
uh but yeah this is the first time we're
live on both
uh twitch and youtube so hello to the
people in the in the twitch chat for the
first time uh john z abraham and chess
thinker
and hello to the youtube regulars as
well
hello hello so what is black's idea with
knight g6 why are we not going after the
d4 pawn
it's real anish all right i trust the
chat room anish geary
watching uh 2200 talk about him winning
the magnus carlson invitational
very good stuff all right nobody knows
what the point of knight g6 was
so instead of playing knight f5 and
going after the d4
pawn knight g6 is actually telegraphing
something a little bit different
due to white's play by bringing the
knight out to a3 and back to c2
black is sort of admitting that okay
you've got some really nice control over
d4
i'm going to start attacking somewhere
else so in openings like the french and
other sort of closed
center positions there's usually two
ways you can go after the center
one is by attacking the base of the pawn
chain and that would have been with
knight f5
going after d4 and the other is
occasionally you can attack the head of
the pawn chain
in this case the e5 pawn so of course f6
is going to be the point here now the
knight on g6 is applying a little bit of
extra pressure
to the center with black going after the
head of the pawn chain
rather than the base and did my mouse
cursor look at that that's wild we're on
a different computer i love it
okay all right i won't wiggle the mouse
too
too much that was that was fun um anish
isn't perturbed though he just takes on
f6
and we get g takes f6 and castles
uh black now continues with bishop to d6
so this is a really interesting type of
position i find these positions to be
some of the most interesting really in
all of chess
and now why is that well there's a
really nice
imbalance going on here black of course
sort of has a central
advantage right we have black with these
claims
in the center controlling a whole lot of
central squares and some of these
squares on the king side as well
so on the surface it looks like these
pawns are doing a really great job of
controlling
nearly every important square and then
we see black is also eyeing this
f4 square thanks to this knight on g6 as
well
so what's the drawback to this well of
course black's position is starting to
look a little bit airy of course these
two pawns
you know have no pawns left on the
seventh ring to help defend them
and this is going to be the source of
white's counter play but this is
actually very very difficult
sort of needle to thread for white here
because
if white doesn't manage to apply some
real tangible pressure to these pawns
pretty early on then black is just going
to be better right you know
someday when black has a safe king we'll
see black launch an h pawn down the
board
use these pawns to control every square
in front of his king perhaps on f7
as we'll see and black just gets sort of
this free attack down the open g file
you can imagine the rook coming over
here
like black's plane is very very clear
right black is not going to need to do
anything special
just put the rooks on the open file uh
wait for the right moment for any kind
of break
and go after the white king in the
meantime it's a little bit unclear
how we you know sort of transport these
pieces into some sort of attack against
these weakened pawns
but that is what anish manages to do
here and it's actually quite an
impressive game in my opinion
uh so first and foremost though before
we start launching our big attack
knight f4 was deemed to be enough of a
problem to respond to
and that's why we see anish playing g3
here just stunting this bishop a little
bit
keeping the knight out of f4 but this
does come with the downside
of allowing h5 to come with a little bit
more
more oomph for example because now of
course the g3 pawn is a hook
that black is going to be able to latch
on to open up this h file
and accelerate the attack
oh thank you all right anisha's going to
bed uh
thank you for joining um happy to hear
you're giving us giving us a quick shout
out
very kind anish geary in the chat look
at that that's wild
all right uh so h5 and the attack for
black has started
uh and now begins the very accurate
actually rerouting of the pieces here so
anish starts with bishop
to d3 uh already hitting this knight on
g6 and this is
the downside of black's structure it
just leaves a lot of weaknesses behind
and especially after h5 you see that um
yes the attack is coming quite
forcefully but black just doesn't have
any pawns left to defend the sixth rank
which means he's going to have to
sort of stretch his forces a little bit
thin to keep all of these squares
covered
uh for the moment though he brings this
knight back from c6 to e7
really further highlighting that
attacking the quote-unquote isolated
pawn on d4
is just of no interest to yan there's
just
no reason at all to go after this pawn
at this point it's well defended
and black has other ideas so goes to
show don't get too attached to one plan
in
openings like the french there's more
than one way to play the game of chess
all right to continue now anish brings
the knight from c2 to e3 so as pressure
is relieved from d4
anish is saying okay i don't need to
defend this pawn as much anymore
i'm going to do more useful things with
my pieces
i also want to highlight that this
bishop here on c1
is not being developed and
that is something that i think a lot of
beginners
sort of struggle with you know you're
always told develop all your pieces
and then uh you know go about the middle
game plan but oftentimes
there might be this one bishop usually
the queen's bishop
that just doesn't have a great square to
go to for example if you bring this
bishop out to e3
it's really not doing anything it isn't
already doing
on c1 in fact you're weakening your
b-pawn
and taking a square away from your
knight so anish is happy to just let
this bishop sit here it's already a
useful piece
attacking many of these king side
squares so there's no rush
to bring it anywhere else are we getting
knight e3
by anish and now of course h4 by yan
and again i can't really stress this
enough like i would
almost always prefer to have this
position with black uh of course
you know at a very very high level um
it's still sort of a razor thin position
where either side
could grab the advantage but black's
moves all come very very naturally right
we play
h5 h4 we go king f7 queen c7
and checkmate the white king i i can
pick out yon's moves
in these positions however anisha's
moves are
are sort of more difficult to come by
you see that all of these squares are
just entirely defended
and it's difficult to make any headway
with your pieces
to start with though anish does play
knight g4 highlighting that this
pawn is a little bit weak we get king f7
and anish sort of makes the final
improving move that you can
uh locate in the position with rookie
one rook to the half open file
uh jan now plays the interesting move
queen to f8
uh and you know i was saying queen to c7
but of course jan
is better than me so he's gonna bring
the queen into the attack as well
rather than the pointless queen side
square of c7
well almost pointless it does apply some
pressure to g3 but yeah queen f8 instead
keeps this king a little bit more
solidly defended and allows the queen to
participate in the attack and defense
so now chat room this is why this game
is so impressive
right so anish hasn't done too much
that's super special so far
just simple improving moves to bring the
pieces into attacking position
but what do we do now how do we continue
improving is there a way
and i will turn this to you chat room
what do you think
uh the chat says does this mean white
failed to get the advantage in
the opening i think in many of these
blitz games the goal
is because of course this was the
playoff which was
blitz rather than the rapid time control
um
the goal is just to get a position where
you sort of know what you're doing i
think that at least that's my goal in
blitz
i think that actually extends pretty far
up the rating ladder even to the top
these players just want to get a
position where they feel comfortable
and can blitz out some moves very very
quickly
and you know while i wouldn't be
comfortable with weight in this position
i think clearly from the game anish felt
confident here
so i would say his opening is a success
uh bishop takes if okay allen is saying
if black is attacking should whites
trade some pieces bishop takes g6 uh
bishop e3 maybe connect the rooks
dark square bishop is kind of useless
have to find a square form are you guys
paying attention
i was just talking about how this bishop
on c1
is actually already a useful piece even
though it hasn't moved from its starting
square
it is doing a good job of attacking many
of these squares
things like knight h6 are threats for
example and
probably that's why we see queen f8
uh also controlling g5 may be important
later on
and it's always nice to have a little
bit of extra care around
the f4 square now if you play a move
like bishop e3 you're sort of actively
harming your position you're taking away
what could be an important retreating
square for the knight
you're also blocking off your rook so
bishop e3 definitely the wrong idea here
and bishop g6 i don't think is quite
right either the thing to realize
is you're not really trading off an
attacker for black you're trading off
your best minor piece which is the
stellar bishop
on d3 for actually the knight on e7 i
know you're taking the knight on g6
but black is gonna take back with this
knight you're sort of just advancing
black's forces into the game knight on
e7 isn't very threatening
uh and you're developing it essentially
for free
all right now we're getting into the
good stuff uh great wolf says queen e2
and
queen e2 would probably be a move a
patzer like myself would play
some move that vaguely looks like it's
continuing the attack
just improves the queen a little bit but
anish decided enough was enough here so
knight takes f6 is one of the one of the
fun ideas
that the chat room is suggesting and
this is along the right line of thinking
so you know in a materialistic person's
head
these pawns control all of these squares
there's no way we can attack this black
king
unless we you know are threatening to
take one of these pawns
unfortunately that's just not realistic
in this position
you can't add enough attackers to either
of these pawns
to force a weakness by black so that
doesn't leave you with many options
basically if if that doesn't work and
you need to attack the king
you just have to start sacrificing some
stuff and that's what anish does
in this position now looking back with a
computer it wanted to play
queen to b3 with a similar idea i think
to
your guys's developing moves like queen
e2 um
it attacks this pawn on b7 which
stockfish deems to be relevant
and after something like rook b8 it just
wants to develop out with bishop d2
and start diverting the play to the
queen side a little bit
now as a human i think this would be you
know speaking personally as a human i
know not many of us are
but um i would be a little bit afraid to
play a move like queen b3 it feels like
it's heading in the wrong direction
sort of like you know the move queen c7
that i offhandedly suggested earlier
much worse than queen f8
because it's moving in the wrong
direction all the action is taking place
on the king's side
and it feels like this sort of
lackluster queen side attack isn't going
to be good however
stockfish of course calculates it out
better than i ever would
and it thinks this is a playable way to
continue
instead though anish says enough is
enough it's time to sacrifice
not necessarily with knight takes f6 i
think this
could just be captured and you haven't
actually achieved too much
in the way of an attack here but instead
with knight
f to e5 check which of course is
double question mark blunder of course
it's a blunder
so jan takes the free piece now
stockfish can call this a blunder all at
once
but in a blitz game if i'm playing with
the black pieces here my king's on f7
this f file is open and now after d
takes e5
these uh holes are now sort of permanent
in my position
i'm going to be a little bit nervous
against denish geary going to be a
little bit nervous
sam says knight g5 you remember that
being the engine move really
knight g5 here i didn't uh yeah g5 is
apparently playable as well
uh with similar similar ideas but
my stockfish at least says queen b3 best
move and that is pretty i guess
intuitive to me you know one once you
look at the variations
it goes like bishop d2 issue b4 starts
trading pieces off
but i like the sacrifices in this case
knight f to e5
uh we get de5 uh fe-5 de5 and now bishop
to c5 uh
finally now anish does develop this
bishop out to bishop g5
notably though bishop g5 is much much
different than bishop e3 uh
a couple turns ago what's different
about it well this bishop of course is
serving a very very useful purpose on g5
it's number one you know not for nothing
it is pressuring this pawn on h4
it's also threatening to step into
squares like f6
and it it's very useful to be
controlling these squares that's all i'm
saying this is
one of the king's only escape routes in
the position and this bishop is sort of
preemptively
building a box around that king we get h
takes g3 by jan no reason not to include
this
and then bishop c6 which is big blunder
as lee chess says now all this stuff
gets a little bit over my head
but i do understand that bishop c6 is
a little bit um a little bit too much
here so
this is where uh slower time controls
would have been yon's friend
now this is an important thing to notice
about uh blitz chess
in particular even you know five minute
with a little bit of increment as they
were playing here
it still blitz you still have to be
making moves really quickly
so what's the idea of bishop c6 well jan
fell for the classic trap
of trying to play active defense which
is
a big mistake that humans keep making i
i don't know why humans
want to play actively all the time
sometimes it's best to just sort of hole
up
and uh and hope for the best so in this
case
jan plays bishop c6 why does he play
bishop c6 well he wants to play d4 and
checkmate his opponent
you know sort of understandable
unfortunately here
this idea is just not good enough and it
actually takes the bishop off of a very
important defensive square
on d7 so french players love to love to
tell carol players like myself all about
this bishop
how actually useful it is back here
because it's helping to defend
all of these light squares and it turns
out that is quite relevant here thanks
to this bishop being on d7
black could actually play the move
knight f5 here and this is what the
engine gives
as being one of the top moves it's the
one that makes the most sense to me the
engine i think also mentions something
about
a rook h5 move here being playable but
knight f5 i think
is the best why is knight five the best
well you're cutting off
the pressure from this diagonal you're
also cutting off the pressure
from this file and
with this bishop here to support the
knight you never really have to be
worried about anything like this
because the bishop is always ready to
step in and defend
these light squares after bishop c6 on
the other hand
you sort of lose this opportunity to
play the move knight f5 for example
after the best move queen f3 knight f5
would be a massive mistake of course
because you don't have this bishop here
to defend um so queen f3
is actually the best move and that just
comes down to
sort of crazy tactics that are not going
to really be
possible to uh to calculate out in this
blitz game
also yeah hello hello to anybody just
joining and oh my god
am i looking at the twitch chat uh i am
now it's difficult
these two chats i gotta get used to it
if you play chess you would understand
what he's saying i hope so
if you don't play chess this isn't going
to make much sense i would agree with
that
uh help you get to 2000 blitz okay just
watch the stream we're doing it
uh okay so queen f3 obviously it's blitz
chess
and to find moves like queen f3 you have
to calculate very accurately right
uh you know once you are sort of shown
the move it makes a lot of sense
uh just because tactically after king e8
you you have the tactics necessary to
force this king into an awkward position
but over the board or not over the board
in the online game anish plays rook c1
instead
which is a perfectly human and natural
move you activate the rook and again
notice how anish is attacking the king
he's not playing the direct checks
even though it was correct on the
previous turn he's sort of bringing the
pieces to attack these random squares on
the queen side
now what's the point of that well anish
of course is anticipating
that black may be you know running for
the hillside here with something like
king e8 you know
king d8 king d7 and trying to hide on
the queen side so a move like rook c1
doesn't really seem to advance the
attack on this king but it does a good
job of this
slow surrounding idea of the black king
and that's why i you know i'm not not
super upset with this move
uh jan says hey look i can threaten
checkmate in one
so he does it uh anish thankfully does
not blunder rook h1 mate and instead
plays bishop
e4 and we get bishop takes e4
by jan rook takes e4 and this is a
pretty natural idea as well
of course just trading off attackers as
the person who is up a piece
makes a lot of sense uh now after that
we get the interesting move of
knight to f5 vayat which is a nice
little
uh accurate move and if i'm an issue i'm
gonna start to to be getting a little
bit worried right we do
end up with this knight f5 blockade that
jan could have gone for with the bishop
on d7
we've lost our strong attacking bishop
on d3
and it looks like the c file is closed
the f file's closed it's getting tough
to worm our way into this position but
you know anish still has a few tricks
left
finds the move queen to a4 going for
some invasion squares over here and at
this point i would say
just ignore any of these inaccuracy
things by lee chess here
lee chess thought it was -3 already so
you know
it's ready to sort of give up the game
in positions where it's like minus three
or more
generally don't have to worry as much
about playing computer moves it's about
playing the tricky moves
and queen a4 is definitely tricky
starting to threaten
some checks we get rook c8 by yon
and important to note the time situation
here anish with two and a half minutes
yan down a minute on the clock and if
that's not an impressive achievement i
don't know what is
i don't know how many of these online
games i've seen yan
down time much less down one minute with
only 90 seconds left on the clock that's
like
obscene so a niche really getting them
here
really really getting them uh hello gp
uh
okay and john c abraham actually has an
interesting suggestion
of b4 here so i think the problem with
b4
is that bishop b7 is is perfectly fine
uh and the problem is even if you do get
to invade you don't get to invade
forever
it looks like simply queen d8 and
there's actually
some pretty strange tactics going on
here with the the rooks miraculously
getting forked
with the queen on d5 and of course if
something like queen c1 queen c2
rook c8 pieces just start coming off the
board so that's the problem with b4
instead we get queen a4
rook c8 and bishop f6 so this
is the moment where uh jan
plays sort of the only move that loses
the problem of course
is that when you've been playing a game
where you could have played a losing
move sort of at any moment and in fact
had already let the advantage slip once
it's sort of bound to happen sooner or
later you just can't play perfect chess
under these time control settings so
chat room i want to see if you can find
the correct move and see if you can find
the move
that jan played
so what wins and what loses in this
position
there's actually one move that is pretty
you know
pretty blatantly the simplest after you
find it but
the other two options are a little bit
less clear
chess thinker says knight h4 seems
winning my first question is which one
my second question is why my third
question is what
okay so uh manuscupta says king g8 just
adopting the uh give some material back
approach
allowing white to perhaps capture the
rook
uh gogendeep
says rook g8 i'm i know i'm not
pronouncing that correctly but that was
my best guess
and steven says the the simple move
queen e8 and yeah queenie8
once you see this move if you do see
this move i think you always play this
move
um perhaps the the problem that jan
might have thought he saw or something
was some way to attack this bishop
uh and then there's two threats on the
board but of course there's just no good
way
to apply any pressure to this bishop
queen c4 queen c2
neither of those moves threaten to take
queen a5 of course
can be met at simplest i will not by b6
because this is check
but um why is something like queen c6
making another threat or even bishop b6
uh
making yet another threat and then
plenty of time left to save the rook
so queen e8 is definitely the uh the
move here
now the question is between rook h rook
h7 and rook g8
why does one lose and why is one
perfectly fine
turns out rook g8 is in fact winning the
game
this one is good enough for the victory
however
jan plays rook h7 like a patzer
double question mark from lee chess here
and
that is an accurate depiction so why
does rook h7 lose what's the problem
what's the problem with rick g8
there was no problem with rick g8 that's
what jan uh could have played
instead though moves the rook to the
wrong square and looking at the time
jan actually spent half of his time on
this move so it's definitely
not too incredibly trivial uh of a
decision
i think though if young had seen queen
eight jan probably would have played
queen e8 i think that's the type of move
that you just don't don't see sometimes
okay professor has one move but one move
is not going to be enough here
if you want the credit for finding the
line you have to uh to give me more have
to give me more here
engines are far better than human
water is wet
queen d7 picks up the rook well it's not
quite
not quite that simple everybody not
quite that simple
right there there is more to the story
than queen d7 winning a free rook
because you know there's like eight
legal moves there for black
queen c4 b6 b4
that's a little too uh
i don't know what do you call it so it's
it's a little too much
um with all these things happening over
here on the king's side
tactics against this bishop while you
know they might exist somewhere
sometimes
they don't really exist right here
so what's the problem yes queen d7 is
the idea but what's the problem
after king to g8 it's not some random
queen sacrifice
it's just that this pawn is hanging and
the knight on f5 is
going to die super sad don't need to
sacrifice
the queen or anything just a free knight
however
there are no fewer than three different
reasonable ways to
interpose here of course actually the
bishop would hang the rook so maybe
only two reasonable ways to interpose
what's what's the big deal
what's the big deal everybody why can't
we block the check
what's going on why can't we block the
check
nobody thought nobody thought we could
block the check
now growing up i was always told there
are three ways to get out of the check
move the king capture the attacking
piece or block the check so i think we
do need to think about blocking the
check
unless i learned the rules incorrectly
remove the defender then pick up the
rook really good
man i don't is this like do you guys
know chest notation
but yes of course we remove the defender
and then pick up the rook
very good i agree so bishop takes
why not knight takes well of course
there's a rook f4 check
and black's pieces are just too
unfortunately placed here
and this is what you get jan this is
what you get when you make loose pieces
loose pieces drop off rook on h7 that's
a loose piece should have gone
to g8 instead now what would have been
the difference here well of course
now this rook on c8 is defended and we
can simply guard
with the bishop with no fear of rook
takes c8 so that's why rook g8
is better than rook h7 not necessarily
because this rook is loose
because this rook is going to be loose
after queen d7
and this is sort of how the game goes
anish finds the tactic
uh jan tries to hold on here gives up
the rook on c8
but at this point it's just too much now
the king is weak
white is actually up in exchange and the
end of the game follows without too much
more controversy
uh queen h5 check rook g4 and the
weakness of the king
did tell this story at the end of the
day
if that is a saying that people say
uh okay so you guys i think
in some manner sort of found the queen
d7 tactic
um i don't know you guys were just so
averse to actually typing out the moves
uh chess thinker had some moves in the
twitch chat but of course i was too late
to read them loose pieces sink ships
that's a good saying i'm gonna start
saying that one
uh and so yeah that was tiebreak number
one so any questions on tiebreak number
one here again
this move knight f to e5 big blunder
according to computers
but it's the type of like you know this
is this is
this is mikhail tell right there tal
would play knight e5
and then somehow miraculously win the
game um
you know except he would do it in
classical time controls so
throwing down the gauntlet to a niche
there start sacrificing pieces like this
in your over the board games i'll be
really excited and so
this is why this is one of my favorite
games from the
from the match here
all right hello manny in the twitch chat
we're we're dual streaming here today
fun stuff um seeing no questions though
let us move on
to game number two in the tie break so
of course
anish off to a star strong start in game
one
takes the lead yon is now in a yet
another
must-win situation to even get to the
tie breaks he had to win a must-win game
in the rapid portion and now yet again
he was in a must-win scenario and let's
see
the exciting opening that jan goes for
now that he has to win you know what
will we see will we see more sicilians
will we see some d4 opening no no jan
plays b3
what a troll what what what an actual
troll plays b3
in his must win game with white
for those of you unfamiliar why is b3
sort of a strange idea
for a must-win game and on the other
hand why is it potentially a good idea
well the problem with b3 is that there
are about
12 maybe 13 14 different lines
that all give black pretty easy equality
i might be exaggerating a little bit
but there are a ton of different ways
that black can play here
and pretty much all of them equalize
very very easily so
that's why b3 is a strange choice to try
to get an exciting game because with so
many lines to choose from black
should be able to find some way to get
an easy equality without too much
problems
now the upside of playing a move like b3
is that you're just
you're going to get a chess game right
that's i'm pretty sure that's all yan
was looking for here
just wanted some kind of chess game it's
five minute time control mistakes are
going to be made
sort of inevitably and he's taking his
chances with that
anish though continues with d5 uh
of course e5 is but okay we get d5
bishop b2
bishop f5 by anish and he just sort of
goes for this very simple setup
that uh you see players with the black
pieces sort of
going for all the time just knight f6
knight c6 to follow
you develop your pieces you control the
center and black can't be worse
it's that easy uh knight d2 by yawn
we get knight f6 and now g3 knight c6
bishop g2
and e5 so at these high level games
you'll always see if one player
is not taking over the center the other
player is usually happy
to to oblige having a strong center
usually not a bad idea
now is e6 a bad move here uh honestly
maybe yes because you're sort of playing
into the white's hand here of playing
against this bishop on f5
it doesn't have a very bright future
staring at this d3 pawn white's probably
going to play e4 at some point this
bishop just won't be the most useful
so how does e5 change that well now
after something like e4
we're actually going to retreat the
bishop on this diagonal and this is
actually exactly how the game goes
so now rather than being relegated to
the g6 square we have this bishop on a
nice active e6 square
controlling some important squares like
c4 and the king's side as well
knight g to f3 is the continuation we
get now queen to c7
uh calmly defending this pawn and
kingside castles
bishop e7 uh which lucha doesn't like
but
it's fine it develops and
knight to c4 so question chat room
um should we be capturing
this night yes or no
bishop takes knight what are your
thoughts on this move
and he said in one of the interviews
after the game that he'd actually looked
at 1v3
well we could have asked him a little
bit ago he was in the chat
very very strange
exquisite corpses b3 is a real move but
it's one of the least real moves fair
enough
why not knight g5 it's a good question
so teos says no because white will have
a strong d5 square interesting
audi says it doubles the pawns so yes
d5 is permaweek
so first of all it's important to
realize what's the alternative
because white is making a threat here so
our alternative is to play something
like knight d7
right so what do you guys think is it
better to play something like knight t7
or bishop takes c4
all right and the chat's mad at me for
saying f5 is always a bad move it's
unfortunate
uh chess thinker says i will take it
then rook d8 knight d4 at some point so
in fact
anish does capture on c4 he actually
plays rook d at first but it's
effectively the same thing
so why are we okay with playing bishop
takes c4 here
rather than something like knight d7
well the fact of the matter is
this knight was not not stopping on c4
it's coming to e3 and it's coming to d5
and a big reason why the chat was saying
you don't want you don't want to take on
c4
is that now your d5 square is
permanently weak
um but you know a wise man once said
something like
it's only a weakness if it can be
attacked or in this case it's only a
weak square
if the opponent can actually get to it
and it's going to be a long path
to try to get to this d5 square right
white is going to have to jump through a
lot of hoops
to get here versus if you had played
something like knight d7 or even
rook d8 knight d7 for example not bishop
d7 but knight d7 to defend
um the fact of the matter is that this
knight is still still just coming here
this knight is coming to d5 anyways
you're not stopping black from you're
not stopping white from playing c4
in knight d5 just just on its own
so really you are playing more into the
weakness of
the d5 square by not taking the knight
than you would be
by capturing the knight so for example
here if something like castles
uh maybe even c4 first maybe knight d5
immediately
but there's no way to stop this this is
just just this is happening
this is happening to you it's so sad i
know i'm terrified but it's happening
so anish snaps on c4 um
and by the way rook d8 queen b1 does
happen queen b1
looks as weird to me as it does to you
guys uh don't fully understand
just some weirdness with wanting to
defend the pawn like this and having
this rick
i i don't know i have no idea i would
have played queen e2 i think
everybody would have played queen e2
here but john plays queen b1 because
like i know he's eon
we get bishop takes c4 now and b takes
c4
notably by the way if queen e2 uh i
think black should
should still be capturing uh on c4 here
no reason not to
um even even if queen takes c4 is
playable but okay we get bishop c4 bc4
here
and now while the d5 square is weak it's
much more difficult for
white to take advantage of it for
example i i am having a difficult time
even drawing a path
like this seems unlikely black can play
g6
this seems unlikely
but possible i guess to get to d5
so d5 is weak but white can't
effectively utilize it
and at the same time black has
successfully made some weaknesses
in white's camp now the huge upside for
white here is that c3 is still a legal
move
in order to eject any piece of blacks
that is landing on d4 uh we get castles
here
so why not take this guy well because
your king isn't castled
dummy your king isn't castled uh knight
takes e5 here is
also a problem with tactics okay so
kingside castles rookie one defends the
pawn
now we get knight back to d7 anyways
keeping an eye on these knight hops
we get bishop bishop back to f1 and now
knight into d4
and white responds with knight d2 which
is apparently a big mistake
so why is knight d2 wrong well it's sort
of just heading
in the wrong direction right there's no
way to get to d5
knight d2 i honestly don't fully
understand
what what the point of this move was and
instead we just need to
fix our stupid queen why is our queen on
b1 why did jan put the queen on b1
what was happening what was happening
does the chat know cause like i still
don't know i looked at it i tried to
understand
i tried to understand the idea i just
don't get it
okay but knight d2 instead we won't try
too hard to understand
and anish finds a good move bishop g5
so this is one of those moves that i
think is unnatural enough
that it slips by a lot of people's
radars here but it turns out g5 is just
a very active square
for this bishop and this is something i
would encourage you to
keep an eye on in your games these sort
of unorthodox diagonals sometimes
can come in can come in handy quite
often for example
you know i know of course bishop b5 is
an idea and many night orbs to get this
bishop out
but even here it's just a very active
piece on this diagonal traditionally
occupied by white's bishop
in this case white's bishop is sitting
on b2 because white thought that one b3
was a good idea
uh okay we get uh
bishop takes d4 by yawn and now bishop
takes d2
by anish and the tactics
happen like so and we end up
with the classic goodnight versus bad
bishop all that's left to do is convert
so why is this the line we get well
because there's there's really nothing
better to do here there's really
no other way out you you can play
something like knight b3 but you hang
the rook
if you play rook d1 then it's it's all
the same you can't take this because
again
you hang the rook so things just went
badly for yon in this opening
and now we get knight to c5 and dion is
in deep deep trouble if queen e2
94 trades more pieces this could be the
issue this could be the issue this could
be the reason behind the mysterious
queen uh queen b1 although i
really don't think that black is looking
to play something like knight
knight d4 here um but yeah queen b1 just
doesn't sit right with me
doesn't sit right weird mistake to make
we get knight c5 though and now bishop
d3
so chat let's test your technique let's
test your technique
you know the flurry of the tactical
exchanges has sort of happened
the position has calmed down white is
building
a little bit of a fortress here how do
you continue
this game what is your winning idea
how do you add more pressure here
how to add more pressure
dh in the chat says you're new to chess
is this actually yan and anish geary
we are analyzing a game that they played
in the magnus carlson invitational this
is not
a live game i understand the confusion
though because their names are right
there
they're right there but it's me i'm
moving the mouse look at me go
hello gustavo hello hello
okay chess thinker all right the twitch
chat is the chat of long variations i
love it so chess thinker says queen a5
with queen c3 and rook d6 coming
and rookie 8 and rook e6 i guess this
one in rook
a6 so that's a lot of chess moves there
chess thinker
have you considered that white gets to
move as well
have you considered that you need to
type some white moves as well
okay and the other people in the twitch
chat and some in the youtube are making
the mistake i would hope you make with
the move of
i would hope you would make with the
move of f5 so
even if f5 is a good move you should be
very
very very hesitant to play a move like
f5
now why should you be hesitant because
f5
is giving yon exactly what he wants here
with the bishop against the knight
with this pawn on e4 and c4 this bishop
is entirely useless
after f5 and e takes f5 yes
you get to start rolling down the center
but all of a sudden this bishop has a
target
it has a half open or a basically open
diagonal
that it can attack down this pawn ever
moves yes it's a very valuable pawn
this bishop is suddenly a very very
powerful piece so
moves like f5 even if they appear good
you want to really really avoid
moves that open the position you have
sort of your ideal scenario here
just a strictly active and safe and
secure knight
against a strictly passive bishop so no
need to tempt fate with things like f5
this is simply
not a correct idea instead you should
activate the rooks
with something along the lines of what
chess thinker was saying
now i don't think you need to start with
queen a5 queen c3 i think this is sort
of putting the cart before the horse
here
don't really want to be leading with the
queen in
a situation like this in my opinion at
least because it can be a little bit
vulnerable
to attacks still for example even
something
crazy like a4 and rook a3 at some future
date
is not entirely out of the question just
to start
evicting some of these pieces but i do
like rook d6 and this is
what anish giri plays so you just start
activating the rooks
start going after these weaknesses on
the queen side that are already there
and at you know at no point should you
be considering moves that help to open
the position
like f5 even if black is still doing
well
even if black is still doing well is
knight a4 any good so knight e4 might be
okay as well but your knight is already
pretty ideally placed here these rooks
aren't doing anything
the knight is doing a great active job
of attacking e4
and you know knight f4 is the is the
kind of move you would play
when it makes a threat that's kind of
unstoppable you play knight a4
when you're ready to play nate c3 with a
direct threat knight a4 here like i i
think it's fine
but like honestly i'm i'm not even happy
with allowing
white ideas like c5 giving up a pawn for
free
but with the idea of activating this
bishop a little bit i wouldn't even be
happy
with this just total lockdown for the
bishop
because let me tell you a secret chat
room bishops are pretty good
you know this is a bad bishop now but
give it a little bit of leeway and it
can very quickly become a good bishop
all right i'm noticing though that we
are running short on time so let's pick
up the pace a little bit we get rook d6
rookie to bayon just a defensive move
guarding this guy
and hoping against hope for something
like f5
we get rook a6 and now rook a4
anisha is just bringing in the pieces
here uh jan
goes for some sort of attack on the
king's side f6 though to help shore
things up
we get queen h5 now and rook a3 is
already making
some very difficult threats for white to
deal with rook back to d2 now and now
queen a5
and rook a2 anisha's already picking up
pawns and white is basically
helpless to do anything about it i'm
just going to fast forward a little bit
because not too much more uh in the way
of interesting things
is going to happen this game we get e to
we get f4 by yan this is sort of the
only idea
yan could have gone for again just
desperately you need to open the
position
uh in order to get any kind of counter
play and at this point we do see a niche
ready to play e takes f4
but i want to stress the only reason why
anish is allowing the position to open
is because he's ready to trade off the
knight for the bishop so we get
g takes f and immediately aneesh says no
you cannot have this bishop anymore i
will be taking that off the board
and picking up some more pawns now and
the game is reaching
a conclusion we get queen c6 and after
queen d5 check
i don't know if queen c6 was intended or
queen d5 was intended probably
queen d5 was on purpose but it's
simplifying now
and anish just has too much stuff
too much stuff for black to deal with we
get the rook coming to g5
another check and f2 is the game-winning
tactic here
can't take the rook because black will
queen and
that is the whole story here anish
winning the second tie breaking game
and uh winning the magnus carlson
invitational in
impressive style uh so that is about all
we have time for
uh here chatroom thank you guys so much
for joining me again i know we're at a
rather early hour here tonight
maybe we should stream at this hour more
often if it means a niche geary
is going to be awake and we'll drop by
uh fun stuff
be sure to stay tuned dennis boros is
going to be coming on with another
exciting class for you guys
hopefully you stick around for that one
uh let me know if
it's worth doing this dual streaming
thing to twitch i think it went pretty
well
it is sort of strange for me to check
two chat rooms but i had a lot of fun
with it
um but okay that's it for me this is me
signing off thank you all so much for
watching and i will see you next time
you